Britain's Financial Capitol quiet empty
the wards meant to be the height of the
working week it began as a novelty but
it's fast becoming an uncomfortable
reality and now a bleak message from the
British government that while the virus
looms and lingers there will be no
return to normal if we rush to relax the
measures that we have in place we would
risk wasting all the sacrifices and all
the progress that has been made and that
would risk a quick return to another
lockdown with all the threat to life
that a second peak of the virus would
bring and all the economic damage that a
second lockdown would carry the
government's been asked repeatedly for
an exit strategy from current
restrictions the answer continually
given it's too soon to tell in a major
new study by the Office of National
Statistics half of all British adults
say the virus is affecting their sense
of well-being contributing to heightened
levels of anxiety with many people
citing financial worries the virus is
affecting the health of the nation in
more ways than one and according to
recent findings we aren't all in this
together we know men are twice as likely
to die of the virus so too are those
with underlying conditions but also at
greater risk people in poorly paid jobs
and those from black Asian and minority
ethnic backgrounds who are 30% more
likely to become critically ill many of
those contracting the virus are
essential workers bus drivers cleaners
and caregivers in the National Health
Service this is Mary
Ogawa a group on an NHS nurse she was
pregnant when she tested positive for
kovat 19 but died soon after her baby
was delivered alive and well by
emergency caesarean a formal review is
to be launched to understand the
deepening disparity in deaths but their
suspicion is that long-standing
inequalities in wealth and health means
some are more likely to lose their lives
Nev Barker al-jazeera London